The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: I want to tackle
another interesting and rather
confounding issue in relation
to the space and social content
of cities.
And that has to do with the fact
that not all people in society
agree with the ideology that the
city maintains for the moment,
or the society maintains
for the moment.
To change the world is an
ambition of many people,
or groups of people, who believe
that they can artificially
create environment which of
a higher order of goodness
than the environment with
which they now are presented.
Often, these situations
come about as a reaction
to something negative
about the existing city.
We will go through
a number of these.
Obviously, this is a very
large subject, again,
and needs a need for me to
make a few arguments about it
rather than ending with
the complete bibliographic
explanation of all
of the attempts
to identify the
intentional communities
within the Metropolitan area of
cities or isolated from them.
The word utopia has
a double meaning.
In Greek, utopia means no place.
Utopia means that you, the
single you, is a good place.
Already the double
Greek word meaning
indicates some characteristics
of which we have to deal with.
The created environment
in these cases
are meant to create
a good world,
but they also are isolated.
The word is first
used in English
by Thomas Moore's
book in 1516, where
he describes a utopian island.
It's an island which
already indicates
that it's separate
from other existing
phenomena, physical phenomena.
Secondly, it has 58 spacious and
splendid cities on the island.
The island is 200 miles long.
There's equity of
property enable.
The houses are never locked.
No private possessions
are tolerated.
The owners change
every 10 years,
and they're selected
by drawing lots.
So really, you find in the first
of the utopian explanations,
or exercises, as
association with equity,
that this is a place where
private property is not
significant.
There's a random distribution
statistically made available
through the drawing of lots.
Many of these themes involving
a boundary condition involving
the distribution of
resources, involving
the maintenance of the
society are characteristics
of these ideal communities.
[INAUDIBLE] more right of
the ideal state or about
the new island of nowhere.
There's a notion
that this environment
can exist in a sense nowhere,
which means that he doesn't
touch another environment.
There's an interesting linkage
of people during this time.
For instance, looking
back with the great book
by Edward Bellamy, in
the 1850s, describing
Boston as a communist city,
mechanically controlled
communist city, in
which a man falls
asleep and wakes up 100 years
later and he sees Boston
transformed.
Mechanism is an
important attribute
to that changed environment.
So compelling was the book
that it sold millions of copies
here in the United States.
It was a bestseller.
It was read by a man called
William Morris in England.
William Morris was a
great [INAUDIBLE] founder
of the socialist
league in England,
a man of enormous
significance, who
wrote a book called
News From Nowhere,
completely antithetical to the
concentrated vision of Bellamy.
For him, a decentralist
solution which
abdicated the role of
cities with the option.
For here, at the same time, we
have two 19th century figures
not in contact with each
other, but their works
are in contact with each other.
The one comments on the
other's by writing a book.
News From Nowhere also refers
to Samuel Butler's book Erewhon,
and Erewhon is an
anagram of nowhere.
I'm just trying to indicate
to you the density of interest
in this phenomenon.
The 19th century
which is our focus
is the century of
great expectations.
Much though enormous
problems were manifest.
There was a sense that, given
the right kind of conditions,
solutions would be found.
Great Expectations is
again a novel by whom?
Who?
Dickens, Charles Dickens,
it's hes 13th novel.
What happens in
Great Expectations?
A young orphan by
the name of Pip
encountered wonders in
a field and encounters
an escaped convict.
His life is then is the
subject of this book.
It's a book about how you can as
an orphan encounter an escaped
convict and still make
a success of things.
Many of these utopias are
subject to the creation
of new models of
social relationship as
antithetical to what exists.
If the family is
weak, the kibbutz
takes children and separates
them from their families
and rears them separately.
So there's a
[INAUDIBLE] an Institute
for the Promotion
of Social Character
in New Lanark, Scotland.
So does the French
utopianists [INAUDIBLE]
in [INAUDIBLE],,
all of these places
have environments where
children can grow up
independent of the family.
The notion of in loco
parentis is established
to provide the rights for
people who look after children
separate from their family.
If the society exhibits
great Puritanism,
as Victorian society
did, Charles Fourier
proposed his utopian
project, the phalanstery,
on the notion of
passion, sexual passion.
Humphrey Noyes in
the United States
is personally somebody
to be hugged and created
Oneida, the town of
Oneida, in New York state.
If drink and alienation
and drugs are the problem,
Owen's reform of character--
Institute for the Reform
of Character in New Lanark.
Pullman explicitly
says, I will not
allow my workers to own
houses, because that
will mean they will
become separate and want
to live an independent life.
I want them to behave according
to the rules, which I said.
This is paternalism,
which of course, resulted
in complete decay
of the community.
If the outside world is a
new secular world changing
very rapidly, the
response of the Shakers
is to create a religion
which remains absolute.
No sexual intercourse
is allowed in
[? Shakerdom, ?] which
creates a fundamental problem
of population increase.
So it has to convert people.
The notion of converting
people because you have a truth
is fundamental to
certain religions today.
I dislike the idea intensely,
but that's a personal dislike.
So I should dislike Mormonism,
which believes in it.
One good thing about the Jews is
they don't sell their religion.
Or they maybe do
it in subtle ways,
but they don't missionarize.
Missionarism is an
interesting phenomenon,
but it's only the result of a
belief in an absolute truth.
If industrial chaos is what
we encounter in the existing
world, you'll find
the paternal order
of factory towns of
Pullman outside Chicago,
South of Chicago; Port Sunlight,
the factory town of the Lever
Brothers in England, Bournville,
the factory town of the Cadbury
family, and so on.
If you believe the
result of the chaos
is centralized
order or disorder,
you opt for options
for decentralization.
William Morris believes
that over time, Manchester
and London would
disappear and be replaced
by a small-scale,
self-supporting, landscaped
environment, which I'll detail
a little later in the class.
Or you believe in the
work of Peter Kropotkin,
the first urban geographer,
the Russian Prince
who disagreed with Marx
about the new state,
arguing that a centralized state
was likely to fail in favor
of a decentralized order.
He argued that even during
his stay in England--
I can't remember the date-- at
the end of the 19th century,
he said that 80%
of the factories
only employed 8 to 10 people.
He was enormously impressed by
the Jura region of Switzerland,
J-U-R-A, which is the home
environment of Le Corbusier,
by the way.
What impresses Kropotkin
is the capacity
of watchmaking to
organize itself there.
There are many enterprises,
all small, all competitive, all
producing good product.
So his referenced to industrial
chaos is agglomeration.
And he disputes
agglomeration economics
as fundamental to the production
of first-class industrial
product.
That's just the list
of the antidotes.
And the-- I'm just going to
go through, very briefly,
some more characteristics
of these places.
There's often an
authoritarian order socially,
but they're
economically democratic.
The authority is necessary
to maintain the tension
and to distract
from the attraction
of the outside world.
There's no question
of choice here.
If choice is economic,
well, that's OK.
But if it's social,
it's dangerous.
These projects all
have boundary problems.
They need to be separate, but
they can't exist separately.
The Shakers need new
inputs of population.
They often need--
many of them are
agricultural and industrial
businesses, which
is the economic base,
and they need markets.
You can't eat your own food
and maintain yourself totally.
You need a means, something
to change, producing income.
You get what?
These places don't
locate in the wilderness.
But they're located in
the middle landscape,
which Frank Lloyd Wright
understands very well.
His the notion of
usonianism is really
a way of dealing with
the middle landscape.
He built 615 houses in Oak
Park and the Unity Church
in this middle landscape.
I'll deal with
Broadacre City a bit
later on, when we're
dealing with Wright himself.
The difficulty about how
to be yourself and yet
be a part of a
group, how to change
and yet to remain the same.
Many of the critics of these
intentional communities
talk about how rigid, fixed,
without much process--
they are wooden, mechanical,
contrived, inanimate.
I visited the drug
rehabilitation commune
north of San Francisco
called Synanon.
Synanon was dealing with people
fighting heroin addiction.
We were met at the
airport with people
dressed in black leather
on black motorcycles
and escorted to Synanon.
Synanon was headed by
a man, a single man,
who had a mad impulse that
the only way to cure heroin
was to be as tough
as the drug itself.
In theory, it was a
fascist community.
If he decided that you
shouldn't have wives,
you don't have wives.
If he decided that
people should--
one morning, he wakes up, and
says there'll be no smoking.
There'll be no smoking.
At the same time, Synanon
had people in it--
drug addicts who are
highly confident people
other than their addiction.
Lawyers, businessmen
who lived in Synanon,
because it was a better
option than anywhere else
there to live.
He organized them so
that they made money.
They would get up early in the
morning and call businesses all
over the United States,
arguing that Synanon
was a charitable organization.
They sold pencils with
Synanon on the pencil.
They were so tough that
they enabled a lawsuit
against one of the San
Francisco newspapers
for talking about them.
They became so fascist
that the lawyer that
was employed in Los Angeles
who worked for the newspaper
in the lawsuit discovered a
snake in his mailbox one day.
The community destroyed itself.
The story here is you have
to be very powerful socially
in order to maintain
the distance between you
and the existing environment,
which you're finding
incompatible and dangerous.
This is an endless struggle.
You can go as far as
to make the community
as insular as possible.
The Shakers controlled
the physical form
of their environment absolutely.
All meat was cut
into square pieces.
They were places
where you could only--
certain places we could
hang your clothes.
You weren't allowed to embrace
somebody of the other sex.
You weren't allowed
to shake hands
with a foreigner, a stranger.
And so endless
epicurean qualities.
Let me just go on.
An interesting theme
here is that we're
both interested in
space and society.
This is a good opportunity for
us to look at these experiments
as dealing with both.
The extraordinary thing
is that very seldom
do change occur on both fronts.
There's an enormous
physical design conservatism
in many of these places.
Fourier's phalanstery, in
taking the versions which
are propagated, looked
like Versailles.
They are large,
palace-like structures,
learning and innovation in them
is the invention of something
called a rue interieure.
Interior.
The rue interieure is
a very simple system
whereby the staircase in
the section of a building
is public and open to everybody.
So that you-- the idea of
mixing is a public act.
The rue interieure
is found-- can
be found, as we'll see
after the spring vacation,
in many of the Russian
propositions from 1917 to '32.
You'll also find it
in Corbusier's Unité
d'Habitation in the center here
where commerce is proposed.
Corbusier will belong
to the same society
of intentional communities
as did Fourier.
This notion between there
being a fixed quotient
for in which you could
operate economically,
you haven't got money.
So how do you innovate
architecturally?
I need to start in an old
building for which there's
no market.
Squatting is part of
these communal intentions.
We will see some examples
in the slides of projects
like Fountain Grove
in California,
which proposed building
an incredible apparatus
of Victorian architecture
in order to create--
attract a community of people.
We'll look at the
work of a number
of these people in the slides.
I've chosen three architects
to include in the discourse.
The three architects
are Tony Garnier,
the French utopianist who
designed a project called
the Cité Industrielle, who
really believes that you can
take the paternalistic factory
town and change it through
architecture.
The second one is
Frank Lloyd Wright.
By the way, Garnier believes--
was an anarchist who
believed that there
would be no law courts nor
police necessary in his town.
The second case is the
case of Frank Lloyd
Wright who really, his politics
are as loose as his buildings.
He designed over 700 buildings.
And we built over 700 buildings.
So when I say
looseness, it means
not necessarily a pejorative,
but a description of the range
of work that he did.
He is a man who
in Broadacre City
proposes that the American
citizen has a right to own
five of five automobiles.
At the same time, he
designed the projects,
the [INAUDIBLE] Center
for Chicago and builds
and proposes--
if he has a political philosophy
it's called democracy.
He writes a book called The
Architecture of Democracy.
But he's really a supporter
of variations on the system.
Usonia is really a version
of the middle landscape
in which the American has
the right to own a house,
have an automobile.
But in Broadacre City, he
also has helicopters flying
over the town in his drawings.
What that's about, he
admires Henry Ford.
Because Henry Ford in
Muscle Shoals in Alabama
proposes a 75-mile-long
city, which
didn't occur because the
United States government
under Senator Norris proposed in
1933 to do the Tennessee Valley
Authority rather than sell
the rights to Henry Ford.
Henry Ford almost ran for--
as president of the United--
for the presidency of the
United States as a result.
Again, there is an
instinct in Wright
always to look at the
opposite situation.
Democracy involves freedom.
Freedom can be assumed through
the manipulation of agriculture
and industry at the same time,
which is Ford's great mantra.
Ford wanted to build a city in
which his workers would only
work half the day or
three quarters of the day
and work in their own garden
and make food for themselves
for the rest of the day.
So we can-- when we look at
Russia between 1917 and 1932,
you have the
extraordinary opportunity
of observing all
of the energy which
transforms spatial
propositions and also deals
with a completely
new social order.
Marx, of course,
disliked the idea
that his thinking was utopian.
He said, my
dialectical studies are
based on the reality I study,
the stock market's prices
in the London Times
every morning.
I'm dealing with
reality, not with utopia.
He disliked Fourier.
He called Fourier's
phalanstere a brothel.
Although Fourier claimed he
was a socialist and so on.
Sorry, Anna.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Yes, I've got--
I've done two.
Corbusier is the third.
Corbusier is a more,
perhaps, complex story.
First of all, he's
European like Garnier.
He has enormous ambitions.
I'm sorry I haven't got
my notes in front of me.
We'll get to him in a minute.
But the basic proposition
in Corbusier's case
is that the plan is the
object of discussion.
The plan is either
right or not right.
[INAUDIBLE] plan
that he makes is
the result of
enormous social study
and enormous physical awareness.
And that, once it is
right, it doesn't matter
what ideology it supports.
His first project-- he really
has three theoretical plans.
The first-- let's leave
Corbusier for a while.
I'll come back to
him in a minute.
I have to watch time because
there's a lot of stuff.
I think I'm going to skip
some of these observations.
One of the interesting ones is
from a student in this class
in 1993 who writes
to me and says,
"A comment on today's
lecture remarks,
'Freud and utopia dreams.'
I was reminded of Italo
Calvino's book, Invisible
Cities."
And I quote, "With cities,
it is as with dreams.
Everything imaginable
can be dreamed.
But even the most
unexpected dream
is a rebirth that conceals a
desire or its reverse, a fear.
Cities, like dreams, are made
of desires and equally of fears.
Even if the thread of
their discourse is secret,
their rules are absurd,
their perspectives deceitful,
and everything consumes
everybody else."
The student says, "Does
that mean the crazier
the expressed desire the
greater the perceived fear?"
And now to answer that.
I mean, it's a very
interesting connected idea
which Calvino in his
brilliant asserts.
There's also a work which
refers to perversion
as a form of utopia.
In a book called
Perversion and Utopia,
there's a "essential
affinity between the utopian
and the perverse
in so far as both
seek to circumvent
the reality principle
which defines the
human condition.
Man has always endeavored to
go beyond the narrow limits
of his condition.
Perversion is one of
the essential ways
and means he applies in
order to push forward
these frontiers of
what is possible
and to unsettle reality."
These are strange
associations with utopianism.
They're not explicit.
I mean, Fourier's
preoccupation with sexuality
is not homosexuality.
It's not sexuality
amongst children.
It's not sexuality with animals.
So, therefore, in our code of
behavior, it's not perverse.
It's about as tame
as Shakespeare
writing about Romeo and
Juliet as young people in love
with each other.
Yet, if you argue that if
you wish to confront reality,
you have to go beyond
certain boundaries,
certainly, the rules of
what constitutes perversion
are there to be broken.
I don't know many
social attempts
to create perverse
communities in this sense.
Maybe they're not on the
record because they're
hidden like dreams.
And the consequence
of fear is so great
that the notion that the
more you exaggerate yourself
and your options,
the more you indulge
fear because the
more the society--
it's such a tense
argument that I don't
know what to say more about it.
Utopia has always been a
relatively gentle phenomenon.
If we see a society
screwing up, let's get away,
make our own little thing.
We'll suffer.
We'll cut our meat square or
we'll go to church every day
or we'll do whatever it is.
We won't have sex
forever, whatever.
I'm talking as if I'm
talking about religion.
There's a certain faith-based
notion involved in--
I mean, take Étienne Cabet,
the man whom I mentioned
in relation to Ildefons
Cerda in Barcelona.
Cabet envisioned an ideal
world called Altruria.
And like many others, he
set out with 89 people--
89 French people--
to the United States
to build this ideal community.
He bought some land
in New Orleans.
It didn't work.
He went northwards
to Illinois and found
the Mormon community
of Nauvoo, which
had been in which had been
isolated as the Mormons trekked
through four cities on their way
to Salt Lake City and Brigham
Young found the truth.
Cabet died miserably in Nauvoo.
His supporters in
Barcelona wrote and said,
can we come out?
And everything was horrific.
They couldn't
maintain themselves.
They didn't understand
the United States.
The United States was a great
place of experimentation.
Robert Owen, after making
money in Manchester,
went to New Lanark in Scotland,
then came to the United States
and proposed ideal
square communities.
There were 41
Fourier communities
in the United States, one of
which is the most interesting
of all.
There's a town in
Wisconsin called Ripon.
It's near Kenosha, Wisconsin.
There was fully
a community there
which objected to the
fact that the United
States was slow in dealing
with slavery in the 1850s.
It said, we're going to form
a new political parity, which
is going to use the
premise of freedom.
It formed a political party.
Which one did it form?
The Republican Party, the
Republican Party in this
country was formed in
a Fourier sex-free--
no, sex-plus environment.
The Ripon Society is
still one of the arms
of the contemporary
Republican Party.
The United States attracted
other Fouriers like Victor
Considerant who built La
Réunion in Fort Worth, Texas.
In fact, the USA was very
much seen as a promised land.
Up to the Civil War, there
130 intentional different
communities.
1860 to 1960, 200.
Post 1960, 2,000.
OK, let's look a bit more
carefully at some of these.
Any questions?
Why do these things fail?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah,
the Mormons didn't fail.
The Mormons haven't failed.
So I'm wrong in asserting--
I mean, I suppose I
shouldn't confuse secular
with religious communities.
In a sense all religion is a
utopia, promises eschatology,
afterlife--
which is a utopian notion
because nobody has ever--
we don't know if anybody has
ever experienced heaven or not.
Heaven is an
intellectual construct
in the view from the human mind.
And the promise of
eschatology, both
in all of the major religions
except for Buddhism.
I don't know what Buddhism
promises after death.
I have Buddhists in this class.
Let's just talk a little
more about some of the--
some of these propositions.
AUDIENCE: So why did
this utopia fail?
JULIAN BEINART: Which one?
AUDIENCE: These-- the question
that you asked, you asked why--
JULIAN BEINART:
Imagine having a--
well, first of all,
the formula is wrong.
The formula is wrong because it
doesn't deal with circumstances
which promote continuity.
Cabet bought some land
in France from somebody
who sold him a piece
of land in New Orleans.
He didn't know that New
Orleans has a terrible climate
and has animals and
all kinds of things.
He landed with a
bunch of Frenchmen.
How the settlers, first settlers
in America have survived,
God alone knows.
But Étienne Cabet
then moved to--
Victor Considerant built La
Réunion on his wife's money.
He exhausted her fortune and
then the place collapsed.
Poor man.
My question is not, I
suppose, why it failed.
My question is,
what good does it
do to us even if it doesn't
fail or even if it fails, sorry?
Victor Hugo writes
that utopianism
is the truth of tomorrow, that
you need in society people who
are going to take chances,
propose alternatives
to reality.
Therefore perversion, provided
it does not harm anybody--
and that's difficult
to ascertain--
should be an allowable
phenomenon, such as I've
often objected to the
Olympic games not allowing
drugs to be taken by athletes.
Because drug taking is
a normal human activity.
It depends on the severity
of the drug, of course,
and obviously as a
model to young people.
But in a marijuana-free
society--
which is probably not
intoxicating enough
to cause you physical harm--
the stretching of the
boundaries of society
are probably an asset.
Therefore I would stop--
I would not want to live
in a utopian settlement
myself because the
very impulse that
drove that utopia is frustrated
once you're in the utopia.
You cannot behave differently
in a Shaker community.
You'll be thrown
out the first day.
But if you went and said
to Ann Lee, who herself
was a maniac who suffered
six dead born children
in Manchester, if you'd knocked
on the door in the morning
and said, "I think we should
have scrambled eggs for lunch
today" and cut it diagonally,
it's just intolerable.
It's, in fact, an antidote
to its own phenomenon.
In order to survive, you
have to be in a decided way.
The political dissenters like
William Morris and Kropotkin
and so on wrongly
placed all the blame
at the phenomenon
of the agglomeration
economies of cities.
He believed that
you could replace
the success of the economic
and cultural success of cities
now finally celebrated
by the whole world.
You must remember that
it's only in recent times,
that when I studied city
planning for the first time,
cities were sort of a strange
sort of curious phenomenon
which people some day
may be interested in.
The first book in English on
the condition of the third world
city was written here at MIT
as late as 1959, William--
what's-- Man's Search for
Shelter in an Urbanizing World.
A man who worked in
India decided to--
maybe these are some
important generalizations
about the third
world city as opposed
to the European American city.
So the phenomenon of urbanism
and its intellectual equipment
is relatively recent.
And talking about hundreds
years the 150 years ago
is not to be taken
literally in relation today.
For instance, Morris--
I don't know where it is.
Yeah.
And the same with Kropotkin.
Kropotkin envisaged, as did the
first [INAUDIBLE] proponents
of the--
Russian, after the
Russian revolution
of the power of electricity
and the electrical grid,
that this urbanist
movement in Russia,
which we'll deal with
after the spring vacation,
was fundamentally
based on the fact
that you now had a
power grid system which
expanded the
possibility of location
in fundamentally different ways.
Of course, it had
other problems.
I don't know what to--
I'm going to-- let's
talk a little bit
about the architects,
seeing as this
is a class which deals
with architecture as well
as with society.
Tony Garnier's
industrial city, which
he proposed as a Rome scholar
at the French Academy in Rome,
he tried to get the Rome Prize
for something like eight times.
Finally they gave it to him.
And they asked-- when he
came to Rome, he had to--
he had to study a
Roman town, Tusculum.
He confounded them
all by making drawings
of a new industrial city.
The conservatism of
the French Academy
wouldn't allow him
to continue the work.
But he did.
When I was a Rome scholar
myself and I arrived in Rome,
I went to a party--
to a reception at
the French Academy
in honor of Tony Garnier, which
is quite an interesting paradox
that they would celebrate the
man 100 years after his life.
Garnier was a superb
draftsman and believed
in architectural form.
For him what was wrong
with the works in Pullman,
Illinois or in [? Bornsville, ?]
or [? Port ?] [? Lever ?]
and so on, the town was always--
as you will see in the slides--
divided into a residential
zone where the workers lived
and the works.
The works was where the
industrial production
took place.
Tony Garnier embellished--
he did extraordinary drawings
of the works.
The works would be
built of concrete.
They would be wonderful, in a
wonderfully built environment.
He said all my buildings
will have round corners.
The concrete will--
they will all
be built of concrete,
which is a new ingredient,
a new structural ingredient.
And all the corners
will be rounded off.
Instead of the residential
quarters of Pullman, Illinois
where people couldn't
own their houses,
he made-- and you will
see the illustrations--
he made landscaped
environments for houses.
He's got the
interiors which looked
like Roman
[? castnock ?] compounds.
What's a Roman house called?
I forget.
There's a Roman word for that.
It's not mensa, it's--
whatever.
Who speaks Roman?
Latin, anyway.
What's Latin for a house?
Casa probably.
Probably casa.
Frank Lloyd Wright cites
Henry George quite frequently.
I've mentioned Henry George, his
name in passing in this class.
Indeed, George was an American--
I don't know what--
economist, I suppose.
What would you say
Henry George was?
An economist?
A land economist, who
ultimately believed
that land had no value other
than what people attributed
to it through use,
that land itself
was only useful for agriculture.
Land itself had no value.
It's what human beings did with
it that promoted its value.
And therefore he said--
he concocted the notion that
Henry Stein and Clarence Wright
used in Radburn and
Sunnyside Gardens
is that the increase
in value of land
is the result of
community's action,
not only individuals' action.
And therefore the
agglomeration of value in land
should be assigned and
assigned to the members
of the community,
not to an individual.
In that sense, if you want to
use the contemporary Republican
Party's definition of socialism,
it's probably socialism.
But Henry George was
hardly a socialist.
Frank Lloyd Wright was
said to have hungry person
that he would imbibe
anything that came along
and justify it by virtue
of its apparent truth.
Corbusier had a different
kind of philosophy.
I'll show you some
of his early sketches
in which he would almost
make scientific diagrams
of the three human
establishments.
He would diagram which of the
three human establishments are.
He would make a section through
a building showing the sun.
He'd do a vector of the
sun in the day in time.
In his section, he would
establish the top of a building
has relationships to the
sun and to heliotherapy.
Garnier put-- he's down
in the Southeast of France
up against the hill.
On the top of the hill,
he put the institution
of heliotherapy.
Why the French are so interested
in being healthy because
of the sun, I don't know.
But it's a tradition of apparent
human hygiene and human health.
Corbusier also proposes
the lifting up of the city
off the ground about 15 meters.
This is to create a
landscape of greenery.
Again, the Europeans always
assume that big moves in cities
are made by the state.
Somehow for him the city
would be made this way
by a new state, by a state,
which would exist independent
of its ideology.
The first Corbusien plan is for
a city of three million people,
Ville contemporaine.
Here the capitalists occupy
the center of the city
and the workers drift
out to the outskirts.
This, nobody wants
to build this.
His second plan,
the Plan Voisin,
which is a plan for
part of Paris, which
removes the existing
diagonal system of Paris
and replaces it
with a set of teeth,
dents, those are
orthogonally-shaped
continuous building environment.
His third plan, when he's
asked by the Russians
after 1917 to come to
Moscow and do a plan,
is a linear, system of linear--
much like the MARS
Plan for London--
in which he puts
housing in the center.
And that is to appeal
to the new Marxism.
He's asked by the
mayor of Algiers
to come to make a
plan for Algiers.
The story of
Corbusier in Algiers
is worth an
afternoon's discussion.
Corbusier makes a whole set of
plans over a number of years.
They are called the Obus plans.
Amongst his most
famous was Obus A,
which has an elevated
highway system running
on the coast with
housing underneath it.
This is the first attempt to
build housing in modern times
under a transportation system.
It turns out to be
very difficult to do.
The amount of noxious material
that automobiles give off
are not certainly something
you want to live underneath.
However, he makes plans like
that for Rio de Janeiro and Sao
Paulo, all dream plans.
So angry with the
response from Algiers--
by the way, he in his plan
to remove the Quartier de la
Marine, where the
Battle of Algiers
was fought, the great movie, and
builds those two towers facing
France, maintaining that
colonial relationship
between Algiers and France,
which Algerians hate.
He's so angry that he
writes a letter to Mussolini
to help him.
The French government is at
this time in a pro-Nazi mood,
the Vichy government,
Marshal Pétain.
They appoint Corbusier as
the director of some kind
of thing of government.
He writes to Marshal Pétain.
He says, please help
me tell these Algerians
that they need to behave.
So he ends up writing to
the fascists for help.
He goes through from capitalism
to Marxism to fascism
like playing the
piano to see who--
who can succumb
to the right note.
For him, the built plan is--
he says it over and over again.
He wrote thousands and
thousands of words in his life
amongst all these buildings.
Why don't we look at some
of these illustrations?
What has happened to
the commune movement?
Would it always exist and
flourish depending on time?
The larger question is how
propositions about alternatives
are massaged within society
or are honed within society?
We have become fascinated
with the word innovation.
What constitutes
social innovation?
Same sex marriage laws?
Certainly, that's an
invasion of a kind.
Even in Argentina,
it's approved.
Our great new pope--
I don't know if this
story is appropriate,
but our great new pope
when he was cardinal
ran a vigorous campaign
against same sex marriage
by the wife of the
previous president--
horrific story.
Anyway, Catholicism is a utopian
venture in a certain sense.
It prescribes the truth
different from other truths.
It doesn't abide by
movements in reality,
such as contraception
and limited population
and so on and so on.
So we have powerful utopian
forces in modern society
who've engaged in great
wealth and great power
and contradict other
utopian ventures as best
they can in a power game.
It's too complicated
to make sense of it.
I want to make sense
of it a bit better
in the second half of
this class where we deal
with contemporary urbanism.
Sir Thomas More on the
left, his 200 mile island.
It's amazing, the first notion,
described notion of utopia
in the early 16th century
should advocate social equity.
He was an interesting
man, Sir Thomas More.
Sir Robert Owen, the young
British philanthropist
who after the
experiment in New Lanark
came to the United States,
the crisis or the change
from error and misery to
truth and happiness, wow.
Truth and happiness
in the United States
is living in an enclosed
castle with a gate.
These communities would
be dotted on the Midwest
much like Broadacre City.
Next.
There you can see one
of them on the left.
On the right is the
best image I could find
of the decentralist's version.
The big city is gone.
Here is in our environment
a non-polluting environment.
The landscape is vital and
indulges farming and landscape
for beauty's sake.
Here's a river.
There's traditional
methods of power.
There are new methods of power.
There's a windmill on the
top, on the hill on the right.
This is the antidote to London.
This is William Morris'
version of what the world would
be like if you could substitute
London for it, a bad choice,
I believe.
Next.
Victor Considerant and
Charles Fourier's phalanstere,
an extraordinary
sensibility that this
is using the same architectural
forms as used in--
under the auspices of royalty.
What is it about
behaving differently
that will succeed if you
put it into a palace?
There's something about
this dream and fear story.
If I dream too much, I
need to supply myself
with nourishment, security.
And maybe architecture
of a certain kind
produces security when
you dream too far.
Next.
Rue interieure on the left,
pretty modest invention.
Courtland's wife made
so much fuss about it.
And this on the right
is the interior version
of the phalanstere
called the familistere
by Jean [? Godin-- ?] next--
[INAUDIBLE] Guise in France.
Next.
And this preoccupation
with the establishment
of the child's world as
outside of the family, these
are children in Robert
Owen and [INAUDIBLE] being
looked after by not the parents,
but by trained educators.
There's something about
the next generation
of people being
uncontaminated by the effect
of the appearance.
The kibbutz movement in Israel
went through great crisis
around the extremes
of this attention
to the education of children.
Next.
The one environment which
maintains the physical form
as an absolute is
the Shaker movement.
This is a Shaker settlement
in Hancock, Massachusetts.
On the right are just
indications of the precision
of the environment.
There is no doubt as to
where you hang your hat.
Everybody will
wear the same hat.
Everybody will wear
the same clothes.
The broom will hang in the
right position next to a door.
Next.
The American scene Humphrey
Noyes and his Oneida community,
also based on some
version of sexuality.
The Rappites, the
Bethel Rappites,
the great movement
across this country.
The Mormon-- next--
the Mormon spatial
program, they lay out
one square mile of territory.
Their houses will be
built of stone and brick
according to the
choice of the owner.
But the layout often alternates
the direction of the plot line
horizontally or vertically.
There's some theory about
that which I don't quite
understand myself.
Can you imagine why
it would be better
to have houses facing
the side of other houses?
I don't know quite.
I never quite figured this out.
But then I'm not a great
reader of Mormonism.
The Mormonic communal
activity in California,
here theosophist community
acting out Aeschylus,
part of the Greeks'
tragedy, a kind
of freer version of
the Mormon program.
Next.
Fountain Grove, how
can I explain this?
I can't.
It's just wonderful.
It's just a drawing for a
developer, the idea of what
would attract people
if they came to live
in a different environment.
Unique versus
replicable plans is
the text underneath
all of the [INAUDIBLE]..
I could live here, I suppose,
if nobody else was there,
if I had the whole thing.
I'd have my own religion.
Next please.
Another Llano del Rio
intentional community.
I think one should look at Drop
City rather than these, Drop
City, which is somewhere
between the counterculture
of California and cyber
culture of the internet.
It's perhaps more interesting
to look at than these.
Next.
Now the industrial
town, [? Kronenburg, ?]
the Krupp family and
Titus Salt, Titus Salt,
Saltaire on the
right, distinguishing
between the works
and the housing
as two separate components.
Not making use of the river as
a great amenity on the left.
Titus Salt bought the Crystal
Palace, but it burnt down.
Next.
Port Sunlight by
the Lever brothers
taking some of the Garden
City ideas of landscaping.
This looks and feels like
a different kind of world
than the world of Pullman.
Next.
And a number of
strange examples,
that happy colony on
the left is by a man
called Pemberton in
New Zealand in which
the center of the environment
could be farms, model farms.
And there would be four
colleges surrounding them.
God alone knows what the world
of colleges and model farms
has to do with reality.
But still.
Here is another
diversion on the right.
I think it's in
Brazil from the 1970s.
And it has a model
farm in the center
and then housing just
distributed itself outwards.
What is interesting
is the variation
of the circular system from the
pervasive grid shown outside.
What is it about
a model farm which
centers a good environment?
I suppose it's basically
from an agricultural world.
Next.
You see the town of Nahalal
on the left by the architect
Richard Kauffmann, 1924, I
think where, again, there
is a central, a central
impulse to create
a central proposition.
And radiating out from
it, it's almost as
if the center is inviolate.
The center has to be held.
What's the poem by Yeats?
"The center holds true."
Some of you should know poetry.
Yeats is a great poet.
"The world falls apart, the
center holds, but the--"
something distributes.
Anyway, this is almost
primeval preoccupation
with centeredness.
We remember [INAUDIBLE],,
this phenomenon
of the center in the pre-modern
or in the archaic environment.
Here is a project by the French
group called [? Commonaut. ?]
Again, the center is what is
the most valuable preoccupation.
What happens around the
center just drifts off.
Now [INAUDIBLE] does the same.
Next.
This is Tony Garnier.
Look at the extraordinary
depiction of the works.
The works is almost more
beautiful than the housing.
The river is maintained as an
important production source.
The ships are managed within
the realm of architecture.
The works are all
along the river.
On the upper left is the
housing, the linear housing.
The hill which is
behind the housing
has the heliotherapy
center in it.
And the communal facilities
are in the black on the right.
Next.
The heliotherapy
center on the right.
On the left, the all
communal auditorium,
all shaped according to
a particular concrete
architecture.
Next.
The house, the housing
environment, this
is such a far reach
from Lever or Pullman
or Krupp or people of that kind.
This is almost the
interior of a Roman casa.
The workers, this Renault
automobile factory worker's
wife is seen doing a toilet in
this extraordinary environment.
Of course, these are dreams.
Next.
Oak Park, Frank Lloyd
Wright's middle landscape.
He built 15 houses there
and the Unity Church,
one of his great buildings.
Here is Broadacres, the
plan of Broadacre City,
Broadacre City, which is a
very small piece of the built
environment.
I think its population is
something like 25,000, if that.
Here the students
[INAUDIBLE] looking
at the project in Arizona.
Next.
The plan is a rather
simple plan, the auditorium
and cultural facilities, a
kind of environment which--
in which the landscape is
a very important feature.
There are lots of
facilities such as open air
stalls for selling goods.
The automobile
population is not fixed,
but everybody who wants an
automobile can have one.
This peculiar
perspective on the right
indicates some kind of
alternative movement system.
The technology of the
automobile has suddenly changed
or it looks as to be changed.
Looks as though it's
got telephone dialing
circular systems on the
automobile and up in the air
some strange piece
of technology.
Next.
Wright [INAUDIBLE] at the
same time was indulging his
fantasies on the left
in a project for--
I can't remember the date,
probably after the Depression
years, the new Chicago life
insurance National Life
Insurance Corporation
and this very small town
in Bartlesville, Oklahoma
for the Price family,
where as I said in
a previous class,
we have the first
attempt in modern times,
I think, to put offices and
housing on the same floor
in a building.
Next.
Corbusier was so authoritarian
in his ambit of knowledge
that he could depict the
greatest human establishment,
the Ville [INAUDIBLE],,
the linear city,
the agricultural
community, the journey
of the sun for 24 hours.
Next.
In the drawing on the
section on the left,
you have some of the key
elements of his building
and also urbanism.
The high, the sun on
the roof, the roof
is given to physical culture.
The center of the
building is given
to the rue interieure, taken
just really from Fourier,
but with no sexuality given.
[INAUDIBLE] the building
itself lifted off
the ground with vigorous
landscape [INAUDIBLE]..
And this is one of these
great buildings in Algiers,
the [INAUDIBLE]
building where there
is a semblance to the
system on the left.
Next.
The first plan, a plan for
three million inhabitants,
the center of which
would be the office
environment for the capitalists,
very primitive ideas
about vehicular transportation.
But still, it was before the
Merritt Parkway was ever built.
Next.
The Voisin Plan, just
allocating his nausea
for the 19th century street.
This is an absolute
renunciation of what
we call the DNA of Paris.
[? Langier ?] said of making
a city, make it like a forest.
There's something intrinsic
in the diagonal through which
our friend [? Hartzband, ?]
of course, understood.
Corbusier introduces
a new form of housing,
a new control of the ground.
Who controls all the
open space that is left?
These great parks,
who maintains them?
Is there any question that
this is an imposition which
is tested on any grounds
amongst the people who
are going live there?
This is utopian in the sense
that it's a free interpretation
of an alternative-- next--
without taste.
He was interested in the
machine and its capacity
for creating linearity.
This is not Henry Ford's
system of production,
but a system of communication.
On the lower slide on the
left is his proposition
for Rio de Janeiro.
He made a similar proposition
along with water--
well, not Sao Paulo
is not on the water.
Sorry, this is
Buenos Aires I think.
I can't remember
everything, pretty.
On the right his work, his work
with the [INAUDIBLE] Group,
connecting all of
Europe linearly.
Next.
His Algiers proposal,
the Quartier de la Marine
on the right side is replaced
by two towers facing France.
The idea of inhabiting
the space under.
What's going to happen to
all of the elevated highways
in the world?
Just about done.
OK, next.
You can also answer the
question after the spring
break when you've had
time to think about it.